hey leute und will kommt zu einer mod
review von einem ort den ich persönlich
als einen der allerbesten der je gemacht
wurde einschätze und zwar geht es um den
mob tor kam odh wie der name schon sagt
könnt ihr damit mit mops reden und
kommunizieren und chatten quasi auf eine
bestimmte art und weise könnt mit denen
so ein kleines verhältnis aufbauen also
guckt aber schon ganz viele südlich
niedlich häufig sagen ihr könnt mit dem
sonnen verhältnis aufbauen könnte ich
mit den anfreunden allerdings könnte es
zum beispiel seines die kripo irgendwann
auch explodiert wenn ihr den blöd
behandelt und so weiter also es ist
wirklich ganz interessant was dieser mob
alle bot alles bewirkt er kraft das so
in dem er einen stock nimmt und einen
glos doch die so übereinander setzt wenn
ihr das irgendwie so macht funktioniert
das nicht
so funktioniert das nur halt wenn ihr
das in der mitte macht hier funktioniert
das überall nicht ich weiß nicht warum
allerdings so bekommt ihr dann so einen
doktor karl stick der aussieht wie eine
fackel mit etwas anderem das heißt doch
ganz einfach moca ihr könnt das auch
hierbei werkzeuge finden im creative
menü naja jedenfalls könnt ihr mit
diesem mob mit diesem motto ging mit cri
von skeletten endermann spinnen zum
zombie spinnen sondern höhen spinnen und
mit wie heißen sie ganz normalen zombies
genauer könnt ihr reden indem er einfach
ein rechtsklick auf die drauf macht ich
gebe einfach zudem trieb hierhin der
sagt okay gut dann mache ich linke
maustaste und ein anderer creeper wert
zwar schon explodiert aber anscheinend
ist er ein bisschen besser drauf und da
steht jetzt bei herb und der macht ein
komisches gesicht also da der typ hat
echt immer komische bilder für die typen
gemalt er schreibt can't get away from
me also wie ihr wisst haben kripo angst
vor katzen und der ist wahrscheinlich
gerade von der katze entfliehen
david lux david lux das kann nicht sein
das ist ein fehler also eigentlich heißt
es dass it looks like this one ag scott
card ins nächste wenn ich würde sagen
würde zunächst sicher wird er
wahrscheinlich gleich explodieren weil
die katze dann direkt neben ihm wäre
wortkarg will ich dann sagen als wenn
sie gar nicht da war und dann ich sage
einfach dass ich die gerade gefangen
habe um ihn zu retten
get away from me aktive take off ich
versteh ich noch was es heißt soll you
are afraid of the cat kg also das sagt
jetzt konkret darüber wait what you das
verhältnis mit dem war jetzt wohl nicht
so gut er hasst mich was ich nicht so
toll finde probier's mal mit dir
das finde ich echt extrem interessant
und zwar kann dieser typ nix anders als
wolfgang und das witzig ist auch ich
mein guckt euch an der abtei körper denn
das sind einfach nur knochen und guckt
euch das bild an das bild ist ja ganz
schön und so aber ich mein alter er hat
einfach nur knochen und naja egal pass
gegen wen ich da hinten wagen wohl noch
in höhlen spinne hier war irgendwo eine
wenn ich dir jetzt wieder finden würde
könnte ich auch mal an sprint man
sprechen wir so einen spinner hat ihr
habt doch gehört wo bist du
hier müsste die irgendwo sein dass da
ein kleines mädchen edward hopper bleib
stehen verstehen in bornhöved etwas
anderes sagen plänen ok irgendwie kam
die grad nichts anderes sagen also ein
paar leute sind echt ein witz wegen ein
paar mob sich das schon leute sind echt
ein bisschen sturm und coop ländern an
what you won't get away from me da als
gateway to do not look at me und dann
you are pretty face bei covering etwas
tier ist also mit tears keine ahnung
also warum verdeckte das what you're
going forward to borrow york apple also
das hört sich ganz interessanter dass
ich seine ender perle ausleihen will
übrigens wenn die rechtsklick drückt
könnt ihr das fenster auch ausblenden
ich mache einfach das hier waterland tür
stranger
das stimmt warum sollte mir die ausleihe
skating around to checking okay ich
glaube der mag mich nicht so gern naja
jedenfalls wir schon gesehen habt ihr
könnt mit mops chatten mit diesem mob
klappt es jetzt nicht nur mit diesen
website wie schon gesagt skelett creep
erhöhen spinne ganz normale spinne
zombie und endermann und du brauchst
mich gar nicht so wird angucken sondern
sonst punch ich dich gleich mit diesem
oktober ding also crafting rezept habe
ich euch alles gezeigt ich würde mich
auf jeden fall bahnhof freuen was ich
noch sagen könnte ist dass dieser mod
noch nicht also zu dem zeitpunkt wo es
hochladen
könnte es vielleicht schon sein ihr
findet den artikel mit dem forum artikel
in der beschreibung wo ist er jetzt hin
ich habe immer noch so ein bisschen
angst vor einem regal jedenfalls ist der
mod zur zeit wo ich das hier gerade
aufnehmen also am 17.8 noch nicht für
die 1.3.2011 punkt 3.1 müsstet ihr euch
dann irgendwie down patchen oder so wenn
das geht
ach da ist er wieder und da ist er
wieder weg entweder den patch oder
einfach warten aber auf jeden fall
ausprobieren ich freue mich über den hof
freuen wir sehen es beim nächsten mal um